hi there reject nation I'm Greg Alba hi
I'm Paula Deen Paula Deming you got to
follow this woman on YouTube and twitch
cuz she's a gamer need i say more we're
covering e3 trailers together and you
played Rainbow six siege so I figure we
should watch this new one that just
dropped from Odessa
Rainbow six quarantine let's watch the
teaser trailer oh and they also have
this first gameplay details
a virus Oh No focus it's quarantine oh
my gosh
[Music]
shooter trailer okay we'll watch the
gameplay walkthrough - I don't know why
I did not think that we were gonna get
like a zombie as rain versus you know I
mean it's called quarantine but I
definitely because you associate Rainbow
six is like realistic military tactical
yeah and then to do the quarantine
elevate combining both of those and
having like a survival horror element oh
that is that's intense that's crazy yeah
I wasn't expecting to just suddenly be
like oh this is kind of scary yeah I
thought was this to me like some badass
team working together yeah yeah well
let's watch the okay the course gameplay
details reveal okay that's tuned as we
just checked out Rainbow six quarantine
at the Ubisoft anything press conference
yes I'm here yeah lead game designer on
Rainbow six quarantine a lot of women
empowerment theme is blood base that the
cold shooter or three players at the
time
he talks a little bit about the
inspiration for this game well it's a
brand new core team that was formed here
in the Ubisoft Montreal and it's you
triangle six fan that wanted to take a
poke at it with the PV co-op aspect that
really wanted to bring a new experience
this being Rainbow six quarantine have
to ask is there a link between this and
Rainbow six see there is you will see a
lot of funny narratives when you play
everything really did - gunplay and also
using your gadget tactics and
destruction but you don't have to be
your
six each player to play quanti so a good
place to pick up and start within the
brand so your tees the few things going
on here we see some enemies that don't
quite seem human and see possibly
something happening with this person's
yes what they'd like to know yes I would
like to know how everything at the first
time so it's a teaser let me to tease
you a little bit that ello individual
that's a good a good eyes what was the
decision to include operator some scenes
in quarantine because they're also
really very they bring a lot to the
battlefield and you know the perimeter
is not just a weapon a gadget and
ability there are a whole personality
people like them they already create
fine art and and about them however
using those operating that context
really make them different they feel not
the same because you are in a PV context
when co-op you in squad you want to be a
tactical and tackle your objectives
again it's gonna feel very different
even though the operators are familiar
oh that's awesome I can't wait to play
it when you pick it up on Xbox one ps4
or PC in 2008 on the PC I'm a PC gamer
she knows that's a unique approach to
change up not just the style and how
you'd like to change your changing up
the overall style of the whole game
you're taking characters from the former
installment bringing in here oh you're
going to P V mode say what's happening
but man I wish she had because I want to
know like are they zombies is this like
a pandemic situation is everyone getting
infected yeah is it like monsters is the
guide the arm from the trailer gonna
turn into a zombie like maybe part of
the the adventure of it because said
there are three players right and maybe
he's one of the main players
you play as and part of it as happening
you know find the cure survive their
quarantine so there has to be some type
of and - Doh - whatever infection virus
is going around following the rules of
many movies I've seen that it has to be
that cool I like the idea of it being
three players you know it's you and two
other friends you're doing it with
friends but it's a small group so I feel
like you can really like get that like
tight feeling I'm like yes a team going
out on these missions together that I
think it seems a really interesting what
I'm really curious to see is if it will
be like the outbreak mode in siege that
you can do because that's a three person
yeah and it's got like alien sort of
yeah threat and I saw I wonder if this
is gonna feel like that or if it's
offshoot of that but they didn't name it
outbreak we named it quarantine well
this is that was just a mode for
rainbows yeah so it makes me wonder how
fans in general are responding this
right now I mean the time we're shooting
this is getting uploaded much later by
the time we're shooting this is only
been an hour and it has 10k up votes in
late 258 so people are really they're
really positively responding to this I'm
sure with the return of the characters
as well it just kind of makes me wonder
like as a standalone game it's so
different like to me this seems like
this would be a mode or some type of DLC
format you can normally toy around with
yeah they've made it the entire game is
this now what I really want is a
gameplay trailer yeah and like this is
just the teaser so who knows when we'll
get more but now I really want to see
what is it like to be playing this game
it's definitely going in a sci-fi horror
territory we're like that's one thing
for sure that looks jacked this dam is
so buff intact in this town that it made
when it went up oh yeah I know but when
I was diagnosed with chlamydia that same
thing happened with me too well then you
understand yeah oh they're fighting
chlamydia
yeah that makes a lot more sense this is
basically dare to resist drugs and
violence mm-hmm
I'd like a game that can really speak to
our youth at a time like this
because chlamydia is a real threat it's
killing people left and right I realized
too that like I was equating like
abstinence education with Dare just now
which really isn't
Clementi isn't like a drug or I don't
think you know how chlamydia you share a
lollipop and that's how you get
chlamydia
that's what it is nice reference to dare
to by the way I forgot you're 45 years
old and you think the kids still this is
where you came for right for this
trailer reaction you came to here yeah
to be to be aware of such harmful
effects out there all right guys what
are you excited for Rainbow six the
Resident Evil could comment below
subscribe to the reel rejects click that
notification bell follow Paul on YouTube
and twitch and I like to give a patient
the day shout out to a man named Taylor
ventilate Taylor for the longest time
I'm trying to get a hold this guy we
were talking frequently on patreon last
I heard from him he got a hot girlfriend
and then he just sort of vanished she's
good didn't mean to be on YouTube
anymore cuz he had a hot girlfriend yeah
had to stop touching himself to me so
that's a bummer for my ego sorry dude
anyway Taylor I've been trying to get a
hold of you I've been giving you weird
shoutouts but after watching this
Rainbow six trailer and just make me go
I get what happened now you must be
quarantined summer
yes girlfriend probably gave him the
clemens and then he has to stay inside
all day through an anti-drug program to
try and get rid of it I'm sorry that she
did that to you dude I would if if I
unfortunately I was able to find a cure
for chlamydia it was a patch I found my
local CVS Pharmacy that surprised they
got rid of it I don't know if you're
making a joke or not to be real honest
with you you can't carry company over
the package yeah but maybe you thought
you had it and you didn't you had
something else in the pack
oh yeah no I I wasn't it was a cold with
Taylor don't be quarantined for too long
man even if you have that virus you just
make sure to go out there just break up
with your girl and spread the disease
elsewhere because then forever those
women will forever have an attachment to
you because of what you gave them on the
inside stop do not listen to this advice
it's terrible
be happy don't go spreading chlamydia
look who do you want to listen to and
how to treat women
me coral woman you crazy
it's all these weird movements are
happening things out of the north all
right this is the weird shadow I've
given her a while take care of guys